pas de rêves
l'avenir je peux le voir
j'ai besoin de toi à mes côtés bien si je ne suis pas l'
avenir de la maison du traité
tu seras toujours la seule chose dont j'ai jamais
eu besoin que tu sois mon fils
combattons comme des démons
mets du muscle
je  n'a pas non
[Musique]
un grand homme ne cherche pas à diriger il y est
appelé
et il répond
mon fils
nous trouverons un
moyen protégerez-vous notre fils
avec ma vie
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas dit que vous étiez un combattant
jessica  tu l'as formé de la
manière que tu vois si peu de
chemin a été tracé espérons qu'il ne le
gaspille pas
sourire gurney je souris
tu n'as jamais rencontré
avant ils ne sont pas humains ils sont brutaux
je suis sur  la lune aujourd'hui
tu te bats quand la nécessité s'en fait sentir
je vois que tu as trouvé l'ambiance que
tu as